health with prostate E. coli infections.
So, prosthetic infections, whether or whether what they are, again, if you know that it's
an E. coli infection, then you would use nutrients that would boost your immune system
to kill that.
If we had a prostate cancer patient with an E. coli infection as well, then we would run
the right machine on E. coli.
If you know what the infection is, and if you have a right technology, you can get more
specific and more frequencies to run.
You don't know what the infection is, then you can run just a viral program or a bacterial
program, and you're hoping to be able to hit it at the time with problems you're ready
to have it around more time to try to hit that frequency.
But definitely immune herbs, definitely with prostate, I would run, I would use also
nutrients for hypertrophy to decrease inflammation of the prostate as well.
We have a product called Prostoclear that has those in it that we use for most of prostate
cancer patients and prosthetic hypertrophy patients.
I would also use burberry with prostate infections and with prostate cancer, that would be a good
thing to think about using, and anti-inflammatory nutrients, so the flaminolates, like co-committed,
as well as relia and stiggy dental, of course, it's in those kind of things.